The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
This is Vannevar Bush, and I had
you read The Endless Frontier,
which is maybe
the most important
organizational
document in US science.
Vannevar Bush--
fascinating figure.
This is his--
He's considered one of the
first great computer scientists,
and he creates this
amazing device in a room
that essentially functions
as a computer that
can do, fascinatingly enough,
differential equations.
And it's room size,
and it consists
of these rods and brass knobs.
And you spend a day setting
up what you want to do,
and then you adjust everything.
And then, you've got the answer.
It's not what I'd
call high speed,
but conceptually,
computer scientists
view this as right up there with
what Babbage thought of and so
forth.
It's an absolutely
foundational tool
in developing modern computing.
Vannevar Bush is a professor
of engineering at MIT.
He understands industry.
He was a founder of Raytheon.
He obviously understood
vacuum tubes,
because Raytheon
was an early builder
of vacuum tubes for a lot
of radio communication.
But he decided he didn't
trust vacuum tubes.
They were too fallible.
So when he put his
differential analyzer together,
he uses these weird
rods and knobs.
Here he is, by the way.
I think that's Frank
Compton with Vannevar Bush.
In the course of war, World
War II, he becomes, in effect,
Mr. Science.
Here he is at the ultimate point
of fame in that time period,
on the cover of Time magazine.
But he's viewed as the mobilizer
of the US science system.
And day after day,
year after year,
it's just a series of "wow"
moments for the American public
as these scientific
advances come onto play,
from radar to atomic power.
And it's a remarkable story.
So he's quite close
to Franklin Roosevelt.
He sees the entire
system being dismantled
at the end of World War II.
So he persuades Roosevelt--
let's hang onto something.
Everybody thinks
world peace is going
to break out and be
enduring, and that the US
military machine is
going to be dismantled.
Everybody's going to
come home from overseas,
and we'll go back to
essentially having no army.
That's what lies ahead,
and Vannevar Bush
realizes what amazing
stuff has been
accomplished in the scientific
world in the course of the war.
So he persuades
Franklin Roosevelt.
Let's hang on to some of it.
And Franklin Roosevelt writes
to Bush saying, essentially,
three things.
How do we diffuse
scientific knowledge
that's gained from the war?
How do we organize scientific
knowledge, particularly
a war against disease?
And what's the governmental
role in supporting science
and private sector research?
Essentially, these questions.
Probably, Vannevar
Bush wrote the draft
for Franklin Roosevelt
to send back to him.
That's probably--
this is government.
That's probably what happens.
He calls his work Science,
The Endless Frontier,
and he's appealing to a very
interesting historical strain
here.
So one of the great
historians of the first half
of the 20th century was
named Vernon Parrington.
And Parrington
writes about the end
of the frontier and its
effect on American history
and American
society and culture.
And his point is that
one of the things that's
very different about
America is that
the structured, class-ridden
society breaks down
in American history
at the frontier.
And of course,
the entire country
is a series of advancing
frontiers, historically.
And that that's the
change agent that
creates the kind of dynamism
in American society,
and that deep sense of
equality that's lurking there.
And when the frontier is
officially declared ended,
like in 1900, it's a big moment.
Because what's the
frontier dynamic
going to be that's going
to keep our society
driving towards new
things, if we don't
have the frontier anymore?
So what Bush is arguing,
in this very interesting
historical sense, is
science is the frontier.
And science, by the way,
is not going to end.
It's an endless frontier.
So it's a very
interesting appeal
to a kind of
American sensibility.
So his paper actually
comes out in July, 1945.
Franklin Roosevelt had
died the previous April.
So it's presented
to Harry Truman.
And Bush is thinking through the
post-war model for US science
and its--
the association-less model
dominates World War II.
It's public-private
collaboration, for sure,
as Max pointed out.
In this document, Bush
disaggregates science.
He separates it back out.
And we'll talk in a minute.
We'll talk a little
bit later about why
he went in that direction.
But he essentially argues,
OK, American taxpayers.
Invest in science,
and you're going
to get some really big things.
And he essentially
argues for four of these.
So as everything's being
dismantled after World War II,
he argues, let's keep
investment in basic research.
That's his case.
And if you invest, American
taxpayer, in basic research,
here's what you're going to get.
One-- you're going to get
a war against disease.
Roosevelt, Bush,
many others had seen
the power of the
development of antibiotics
in the course of World War
II, which really scale up.
World War II is the first
war where people actually
died in combat as
opposed to disease.
The death rate in the
armies of World War II
is far lower than in
all previous wars.
It's very dramatic,
and that war is
being fought in some
very tricky regions that
are quite disease-prone.
And the antibiotics
just dramatically
reduce the death
rate from disease.
So they saw how a
governmental effort
of supporting that science, and
then supporting the production,
and then distributing
it, could create a war--
pneumonia had been
the biggest killer.
It was number one, right?
And that dramatically goes
down after World War II.
It has a huge effect.
So they saw the possibility
of investing in science.
You'll get a war on disease.
It's a pretty powerful argument.
Now, the next argument, they
didn't have to sell to anybody,
because everybody understood
it as a result of World War II.
Invest in science, you
get national security.
And the Cold War hadn't
started at this phase.
It's got another four or
five years before people
will realize it's on them.
But he makes this argument,
and it falls on receptive ears,
because people understand
how powerful radar is.
People understand how powerful
nuclear power is and so forth.
The transformation of technology
was dramatic in the war.
The third argument
is an intriguing one.
American taxpayer,
invest in science,
and you will get what Vannevar
Bush calls public welfare.
What's he talking about?
The big anxiety at the
end of World War II
is, we've got these 16
million people overseas.
They're going to
come out of uniform
and they're going to come
back the United States.
And we're dismantling all
wartime spending, which
is most of government spending.
And we're dismantling
the war machine.
We're going to have
another Great Depression.
That's what everybody thinks.
And you can see why.
What are these 16 million
people going to do?
And we're dismantling
all these industries.
So Bush is arguing, we're
going to get full employment.
And he's going after
this big post-war anxiety
about where these returning
vets are going to be employed.
And so he argues that
essentially, science
creates innovation,
and that the innovation
is going to drive the economy.
All these new technologies
are going to be at hand.
Fascinatingly, we do
get a huge dividend
from all the scientific and
technological advances that
occurred during the war,
and we create a whole series
of new industries coming out of
the war, and it actually works.
And just in case
there was any doubt
about what to do with
those 16 million veterans,
we had to park them somewhere.
So we create the GI bill, and
we send them to universities,
and they get degrees.
So they take, actually, pretty
interesting technical training
they got in the military,
and then greatly enhance it.
So we've got a very strong
technical pool of talent
entering the economy.
And this huge burst--
it's pure Romer right?
And there we go.
We get this incredible
post-war economic growth time
period that really
lasts until about 1970.
The fourth argument
is, nurture talent--
a Romer-like argument.
His point is that
there's going to be
a governmental role in
the other three items,
but there's got to be a
governmental role in backing
this talent base up.
There's going to be a
governmental role in educating
scientific talent at scale.
So Bush has got what we
can call a "pipeline"
theory of innovation.
Here's a pipeline.
We've talked about this before.
The government will
dump basic research
in at the end of the pipeline.
Mysterious things will
occur in the pipeline,
and great
technologies, products,
and a fabulous economy
will emerge at the end.
That's the vision, right?
That's his conceptual framework.
That's what he's arguing for.
This vision of the governmental
role in basic research
dominates US scientific
thinking to this day.
This is where it came from.
Why?
What is he up to here?
Why is he doing this?
Because in the course
of World War II,
he created this incredibly
connected scientific system
with unbelievable results,
where industry and government
and universities were deeply
connected with each other--
a highly connected system.
And at the end of the war,
he pulls that model apart
and says, the
governmental role is not
going to be this
connected stuff.
It's going to be basic research.
What's he thinking?
Interestingly,
he's the person who
created the two most fundamental
scientific organizational
models in US history.
He does them both, right?
They're contradictory,
but he does them both.
What's he thinking about?
Well, to some extent, I think he
was influenced by his physicist
friends.
And physics comes
out of World War II--
people like Oppenheimer and
the Los Alamos project--
with this huge concern
about, what have we done?
We've been hell bent to
create atomic weapons,
and then we don't use
them against Germany,
because the war is ended.
But then we use
them against Japan.
And did we really
think this through?
And what does it mean?
What does it mean
to have unleashed
this unbelievable new
force into the world's
political environments?
Are they ready for it?
So people like Oppenheimer
go through a huge rethink.
A lot of the physics
community does this.
Have we been too closely tied to
a military industrial complex?
As Eisenhower
would put it later.
So Oppenheimer is a close
friend of Vannevar Bush.
Bush testifies for him
when Oppenheimer's security
clearance is pulled
later on in the Cold
War, which was pretty nervy.
He's influenced to
some extent by that,
but he's not naive
about politics.
He understands the importance
of national security,
and he's an advisor
to the Defense
Department in the
immediate postwar period.
I think part of it is
just practical reality.
The federal government
is radically
decreasing its budget.
The cheapest stage is investing
in early stage research.
That's much cheaper than
applied research or development.
Let's hang onto that.
And we created the
federally-funded research
university.
That's an amazing creation.
Let's be satisfied with
having done that one,
and keep that
option on the table.
I think that's a fair
amount of his thinking.
He's being really
quite practical.
But he is trying to remove
science from the fray.
He was very concerned
in the course of the war
by science becoming politicized.
Decisions about where to
put defense laboratories
were based on regional
and local politics
that Franklin Roosevelt
was a master of.
Building consensus in
different political regions
and putting big research
centers in places like Tennessee
had logic, but also
political logic, as well.
And Bush didn't want that.
Bush wanted science
out of the politics.
He wanted to really separate
the political system.
So this is his vision
for postwar science.
And by and large,
it becomes the case.
So let's-- let me do Blanpied's
piece just very quickly--
just a couple of minutes.
He writes the early
history of NSF.
So Vannevar Bush's design
at the end of the war is--
essentially, during the war,
he had the NRDC and the OSRD,
two organizing committees
for US science.
And basically, that's
probably the only time
that we had pretty centralized
science in the United States.
But when Vannevar
Bush ends the war,
he wants to do the same thing.
He wants to create one tent.
So he has this vision
of why to do science
in The Endless Frontier.
Then he has an
organizational model,
and he wants to create
this National Science
Foundation as the tent
for all of US science.
It's all going to go in there.
It's going to be flexible.
It's going to be
loosely organized.
It's not going to be
terribly hierarchical.
It'll be somewhat
like what he was
doing in the course
of the war, but that's
what it's going to be.
And something happens.
He writes up this legislation
to create this one
tent for all of US science,
and what became known as NSF.
And it runs into this guy.
So that's Harry Truman.
And you'll notice on
the corner of the desk--
it's just a little
statement here
that says, "The buck stops
here," in italics letters,
right?
It stops on Harry Truman's desk.
So Vannevar Bush
wrote up and got
Congress to pass his National
Science Foundation bill.
And much to everybody's
total amazement,
Harry Truman gets
it, and he reads it,
and he realizes that the buck is
not stopping on Harry Truman's
desk for science.
It's stopping on Vannevar
Bush, and a bunch
of scientific elite types
will control science,
out of political control
of the president.
Harry Truman, not unreasonably,
says it's unconstitutional.
We can't.
This is an executive
branch agency.
The president ultimately
needs responsibility.
I'm not going to
mess these guys up.
I like science, but
it belongs to me.
So he vetoes the National
Science Foundation Act.
He's influenced by a very
interesting guy named
John Steelman who's
from a smaller college,
but he's effectively
a science advisor.
So Vannevar Bush and
Harry Truman, they
didn't get along very well.
Harry Truman, high
school educated,
never got to go to college.
He was too poor
to go to college.
Very smart guy.
He's an artillery
captain in World War I,
and a very successful one.
And artillery commanders in
World War I are the smartest.
You've got to
understand ballistics
and all kinds of
complicated mathematics,
and Harry Truman is very smart.
So not a dumb guy.
A very talented guy, and became
a highly-respected-- criticized
a lot, but became a
highly-respected president,
particularly in retrospect.
So there's no putting
this guy down,
but he just didn't get along
with this kind of Boston
Brahmin Vannevar Bush type.
And not that Vannevar Bush
was part of Boston society.
He wasn't.
He was from a lower
middle class family,
and his father was a minister,
but they didn't get along.
Bush got along really well
with Franklin Roosevelt.
Not nearly as well--
really, not at all
with Harry Truman.
So they're at loggerheads.
Vannevar Bush is
getting Congress
to pass this without, really,
Harry Truman being involved.
Harry Truman's got his own
advisor, John Steelman.
And they have a
very different idea
of how science can be organized.
There's going to be a
lot more applied work,
and it's going to be much
more associationalist
is their vision.
So the NSF bill
gets vetoed, and NSF
doesn't get authorized
for another five years.
So meanwhile, time
doesn't stand still.
This is why we have this very
decentralized science agency
system in the United States,
because Harry Truman vetoed
the National Science bill.
All these other
agencies are popping up,
because there's jobs
that have to be done.
So the Office of Naval
Research gets created
in the Defense Department.
The great energy, nuclear
weapons laboratories,
Los Alamos, and later, Sandia
and Livermore and so forth--
they all get created because
the atomic mission is there,
and that has to be dealt with,
and they need science for that.
So what later becomes the
Department of Energy Lab
system is being stood up.
Scientific support at the
Atomic Energy Commission
is being undertaken to
support nuclear research.
The National
Institute of Health,
which is a little public
health research agency
benefits more than
wartime advances
in science and medicine.
That becomes the National
Institutes of Health that's
now the monster in the room.
All these things are popping
up, and NSF misses the boat.
It doesn't get authorized
for another five years.
Doesn't really get
stood up until Sputnik.
It's very modestly
funded, until Sputnik.
So this is why Vannevar
Bush gets his--
he's successful in
his basic mission--
governmental support for
research universities
and basic research.
He wins that battle.
He loses this battle.
He doesn't get
science in one tent.
And there's an
ongoing, deep debate.
Was that good?
Are we better off with a very
flexible, decentralized system
of science agencies that are
organized around all kinds
of different missions?
I think my view is, a lot
of disagreement, that's
probably good for us, right?
It creates a lot of pathways
of opportunities for scientists
to pursue.
They're not under one tent.
They've got a lot of
options about what
they go with their research,
and a lot of different missions
converge and come to
bear to support science.
So overall, it's probably
a positive, I would argue.
But the negative is that it is
impossible to organize science
across these agencies.
It is a nightmare.
Getting these agencies
to cooperate--
and again, behind them are nine
appropriations subcommittees--
nine separate appropriations
subcommittees.
You gotta bring those
folks along too.
Good luck.
So central
coordination of R&D is
a huge organizational challenge.
And look, it's not as if
one single agency owns NANO.
You want to make
progress on NANO?
You've got to bring all
this cast of characters
together and get them to
hammer out cooperation,
which is very hard to do.
High performance computing
is a beneficial technology
for all of these agencies.
How do you get them
to cooperate on that?
These are nightmare
organizational problems
in our system.
We finally created the Office
of Science and Technology Policy
as the coordination
entity, but OSTP does not
have budget authority.
It doesn't really control the
budgets of these agencies.
So it can't, in the end--
federal government
money is power.
It doesn't have any money.
So it works with OMB
and moves things along,
but we do not have
an efficient system
for cross-agency
collaboration, which
becomes very critical when
a scientific advance will
affect a number of the actors.
AUDIENCE: What year
was OSTP created?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, Vannevar Bush
is considered the first
scientific advisor.
John Steelman is sort
of considered second.
OSTP-- Eisenhower has
a science advisor,
so Killian, MIT's president,
becomes his scientific advisor.
Jerry Wiesner, also
MIT's president,
becomes Jack Kennedy's
science advisor.
Talk about talent.
Those are amazing characters.
So whether it's
called OSTP or not,
there's a scientific
advisory system
that really endures,
starting with Vannevar Bush,
with the exception of
a brief period of time
when Richard Nixon
got mad at scientists
and he shuts down his
scientific advisory system.
But that gets revived under
President Ford very quickly.
So we've had a pretty
continuous system.
President Trump has not named
a science advisor yet, however.
So that chop is
kind of Home Alone.
[LAUGHTER]
But from an organizational
point of view,
with all these disparate
scientific agencies,
you do need some coordination
entity, from just a practical
governance perspective.
So I think that will
happen over time.
So I've forgotten what
year the OSTP Act--
Authorization Act
actually passed.
It's got to be in the
'80s, but we've effectively
had a scientific advisory
system in place since, really,
the outset of World War II.
All right, I'm done.
It's yours.
And you've got-- and yours.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So how should we--
I could--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
why don't you do Bush,
and then we'll go to
Blanpied and we'll kind of--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Because
they're these two models.
One is basic research
support and the other
is no single tent.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's
the two issues here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So regarding that
single tent view,
I've noticed that a lot
of scientific research
has had problems securing
funding for long periods.
Because often
scientific research,
by nature, is long-term,
and doesn't always
produce useful results.
Actually, this is one of the--
I think Adolph
Hitler, actually--
he tried to ban all scientific
research outside of directly
applied science.
So he didn't want anything
in quantum or anything
weird or theoretical like
that, where he could not see
the obvious applications of it.
So with that, I'm curious
what your thoughts
on our governmental system, and
how incentives can be revised
such that long-term
scientific strategic thinking
can take place.
Because as it is, people have--
they are reelected every
two, four, or six years,
so they have to--
they need to produce
results quickly.
And if they can't do
that with their funding,
then they'll lose votes, and
they could even get kicked out.
So I'm curious what
your thoughts are.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
interesting thoughts on that?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You know,
Martin, I didn't come back
to you when we resumed, so--
AUDIENCE: Oh, the
point I was going to--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm going
to give you a chance now.
AUDIENCE: The point
I'm going to make,
we were talking about
should scientists
be these kind of
political leaders--
I was going to make
a connection to VCs.
VCs are the investment
entrepreneurs.
They kind of look for
somebody that they say is kind
of autistic, which is like they
are in their own little world
and they're not very-- kind of
anti-social, but they focus--
because of that, they focus
so much on the science
that they're really,
really good at it.
And you need someone to
sell it who's more social.
So I was going to go forth from
the model of somebody who's--
it's very rare to have
something can be both.
[INAUDIBLE] I can't
really think of one.
I also don't really
think of Bill Gates
is a super sciencey person.
It would be more like if
[INAUDIBLE] trying to become--
for president.
And Loomis was this person
who listened really well,
and then could sell
the ideas really well.
So I was going to make that
point, that connection where
I couldn't really
see somebody who's
really focused on their art.
And also to Stephanie's
point, where yeah,
that scientist might
lose the ability
to make some key
discoveries, but now
that he knows how the
actual environment works,
he can actually make
any new discoveries
with that framework in
mind, which might be
better for his career overall.
There's this one
idea from scientists,
and also artists, where
it's your best work
comes after your 40s.
You can have long
period of doing
something you think really,
really matters, but [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So let me translate
your point, which is an
interesting one, back to Max,
to your question.
So in a way, we could argue
that the venture function is not
designed into the
Vannevar Bush's model.
That's what he's trying to
pull science out of, in a way.
I'm extrapolating.
AUDIENCE: So he's trying to find
some sort of long-term solution
for this, right, and I was
trying to figure out, well,
what is it that, given
our current system--
as opposed to just
implementing his model,
because it didn't
work the first time--
instead of that,
is there any way
we can adapt what
we have currently
to try to have almost a
hybrid between the two,
so it gets the funding,
but there's still--
you can still have
these separate branches?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You've
stunned everybody, Max.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It was
too brilliant for our group.
AUDIENCE: Or they're
just thinking,
oh it's dumb question.
The first, most obvious
thing I think of
was just increased term limits.
But of course, that
means you have--
that's not great.
That has its own disadvantages.
AUDIENCE: I don't really
see the term limits
as much as of an effect on
research, because I don't think
everyday people are super
aware of the research that's
going on the NIH and--
AUDIENCE: True.
AUDIENCE: I don't even know
how much of MIT funding
is coming from the government.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: 70%.
AUDIENCE: A lot.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I don't know how much
public accountability there
is to that.
I don't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: --if it's as much
of a problem as just the lack
of funding in general, rather
than the lack of funding
connected to results.
AUDIENCE: Or I
think that voting--
votes are typically cast
based on, I would say,
more social or moral
issues, rather than promises
on science advancement.
I can't think of a lot of people
who have campaigned recently
based on--
maybe I'm just
not in tune, but I
don't think there have been
a lot of scientific promises
or campaigns run on
scientific promises.
And I'm not talking
about just president.
I'm talking about two-term-- or
two-year term Congress people,
as well.
AUDIENCE: Maybe they should be.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
I want to bring Chloe
into this discussion,
because we're rapidly
moving into your territory.
So why don't you
pose a question?
AUDIENCE: OK, sort of related to
the topic that we were just on,
the question that I found the
most interesting to think about
from the Blanpied reading was--
you mentioned it
with Harry Truman
and also, I think, Harold
Smith, the director of the DOB,
brought up similar concerns
that it was essentially
unconstitutional
for the president
to allocate funds and power to
a group of private citizens,
for them to redistribute to
fund the scientific endeavors
that they deemed worthy.
So where do you
all have opinions
on where we should draw the
line between wanting only
our elected officials to
be responsible for handling
taxpayer dollars,
and understanding
the value of having our
politicians be advised
by experts in various fields?
And then off of that,
who ought to make sense--
broad question-- not to
make scientific policy--
politicians advised
by scientists,
scientists appointed
by elected politicians,
or-- back to your
point earlier--
politicians who are scientists?
Is it possible?
AUDIENCE: The first
two sound very similar.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think that there
are multiple levels of fund
allocations though, so
I think that there--
in the current system, say
what the NSF, yes, politicians,
I think, are sort of at the
top, and they decide how much--
what the budget
is-- overall budget.
But then within the NSF, there's
a scientific review process.
So really the decision on
who is funded specifically
is farmed out to
experts in the field.
So I think that it's an OK
system that we have, because--
maybe you're talking
about the top level,
the original decisions on
allocation or budget needs.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Lily, let
me build on that for a second,
just from a practical
perspective,
on kind of how it works.
Congress actually doesn't
interfere much, frankly,
with scientific budgets.
It leaves NIH alone.
It leaves NSF alone.
It'll occasionally
interfere with one
of the defense R&D agencies,
particular when they're
spending a lot of money on
actual physical project that
may be related to science,
because that affects jobs
and employment, stuff like that.
But the government more--
it keeps its hands off DARPA
almost entirely.
The Congress actually
does a pretty good job
in controlling itself
from intervening.
And there's an
occasional exception,
but they are pretty
careful about maintaining
a hands-off attitude.
In turn, the US is
organized-- again,
at Vannevar Bush's behest--
it's competitive.
It's a competitive
system, with the exception
of the Department
of Agriculture,
which has a whole lot of science
entitlement funding based
on allocations to land
grant agricultural programs.
That's the only
non-competitive part.
Scientists have got to
compete for the funding.
That was part of Vannevar
Bush's original vision,
and that remains.
And that is a huge
strength of US science.
Other systems don't do that.
There's much more entitlement
science, for example,
in German science.
And they they're actually
trying to reorganize
to put a more
competitive factor in,
because they realized
the value of having
the best minds battling each
other for the best research
awards.
And it's and it's
peer-reviewed, so scientists
are analyzing and selecting
their own science.
So overall, it's a
pretty dynamic process,
and the government
isn't deciding what
science is going to get funded.
That was Vannevar
Bush's big fear.
The other dynamic here is
that Vancouver bush came up
with a design that fit
into a conservative model.
In other words, he's not
interfering with industry.
He's doing basic research.
He's staying out of
industry's way, by
and large, which was
another appealing
part of the model from a
political design perspective
is that he wouldn't
be, in effect,
picking winners and losers in
the industrial applied space.
So he pulls science
out of the system--
out of the political system,
by and large, and that's
more or less where it's been.
Congress does make decisions
about overall funding,
but they don't
really get involved,
except to a very small extent in
actual scientific allocations.
So that's kind of how the lines
got drawn in the actual system,
as it played out.
So in a way, Vannevar Bush got
a fair amount of what he wanted.
His concern about political
interference in science
has never really been realized.
But then, of course,
most of it's basic.
How about one more
point from each of you?
Because I'm having
to watch the clock.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
actually mention
an interesting
question that I found.
So Bush states
that basic research
is essentially non-commercial.
It's not going to achieve
the attention it requires,
if it's left to industry.
So how common was this belief
at the time, and isn't it
as common today?
And has the situation improved
since Bush drafted this report?
AUDIENCE: I think maybe we
can argue that basic research
focuses on these long-term,
not very commercial endeavors
because the point
is you won't see--
it's understood
that you won't see
immediate technological
or economic benefit
from these kind of endeavors.
They're kind of
exploratory in nature,
and so you're going to get
exploratory, only exploratory.
And maybe, just maybe you might
end up with lasers, or radar,
or something.
But the probability
is also pretty low.
And so I think, by nature,
what we deem as basic research
and what we hope comes
out of NSF and NIH
funding allocated to these
basic research ideas isn't going
to be picked up by commercial
or private investors,
just because of the way
things are and work.
And I think we definitely
have seen that in the cutback
in calls for basic research.
And then we haven't really seen
the funding levels aggregate
pick up from sort of
government plus private.
Once you do the math, it doesn't
equate to the same [INAUDIBLE]
funding and basic research.
Even if the government
decides to drop off,
we don't see private investors
picking up the slack.
You can argue that the
government can play both roles,
we can do these public
private partnerships
and also do basic research.
But I don't think
private companies can
have that flexibility
to do both,
just because they can't operate
on these really long time
cycles without any
promise of returns.
AUDIENCE: Just a side note.
In general, companies
that can do side research
is because they're a monopoly.
That's the only
kind of company that
can do side research
like Xerox or Bell Labs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'd say definitely
has improved, at
least in my opinion.
It seems that research
is more easily funded
by the government,
although, of course,
there are definitely
ebbs and flows in that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So the rationale here
is that, for early
stage research,
it's too risky for
industries to manage.
They can't necessarily
assume that there's
going to be any kind
of return anywhere
in the plausible
future, so they just--
they're not going to do it.
It's really out of range of
what their shareholders would
accept.
They can do development,
as we talked about
in the first class,
because that's
much nearer-term
towards results.
But the basic research stage is
much more problematic for them.
And your point is
absolutely right,
Martin, which is that the end
of the monopoly model in--
for example, in the
communications sector,
with the demise of
AT&T, that meant
the end of AT&T's great
basic research lab system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I took a
class on open sourcing stuff.
So I feel like if there's an
ability for a private company
to do--
they'll be doing
interesting research
and decide we're never going
to do anything with this.
Because this happens
a lot in companies,
where you don't want to
disrupt an industry where
it's not worth
pursuing business-wise,
because it's too complicated.
They'll go: we've
been through this.
Do you guys want it?
Do you want to buy it?
I think that might be
an interesting one.
I don't know if it's
been done [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It happens a lot in
bioinformatics and computer
science.
Websites like GitHub,
you know that that's
the repository for
everyone else's scripts
that they've already written,
and programs and stuff.
But for a business, that
would be interesting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Chloe,
how about a close out
point from you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So I think it's
interesting to examine why--
obviously, both Bush's
and Steelman's proposal
encountered different
obstacles at different times,
as we've already discussed.
But ultimately,
it took the threat
of technological
takeover by the Soviets
with Sputnik for
a lot of impetus
to exist to fund research, to
protect the educational STEM
pipeline--
which, tying back to our
earlier discussion of is it--
do we have a system
structured right now such
that the US places value
on this type of research
outside of a stressor like war?
It seems like, at
least at that point,
it's hard to get
that ball rolling.
Which again, is ironic, because
the whole discussion was
started by Bush, who wanted
to draft this outline for what
funding that research might
look like in a postwar era
with the idea for an
institution like the NSF.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good.
All right, I'm going
to jump through
so we can finish on time.
The next two--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm sorry?
I think it might be
cool as kind of a fringe idea.
So you might have--
not really
investigating, but you
might have an idea for a
pursuit in maybe basic research
or something like that, but
your company might decide it's
not worth it as a
business venture.
But maybe it's a
secondary system
like selling that--
like buying and selling
that information might be cool.
So like I have an idea that I
can't necessarily execute it
for whatever reason, but
I can make the idea known,
and then someone else
can pursue and pick up.
AUDIENCE: Like Elon Musk did?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, precisely.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Some people are working on
patent pools, for example,
and amassing patent rights,
which may, in turn, be
transferable and saleable.
So there's work going on
in some of these points.
I'm going to do the
closing two readings.
And Sanam, they're
both yours, right?
OK.
So I'm going to quickly
summarize this piece from Peter
Singer that I put in there.
Peter's piece is a terrific
research because, frankly--
it's almost like doing
genealogical history.
We know what the advance is.
Figuring out the
science that emerge from
is a really complicated process.
But Peter, I thought,
very thoughtfully dug into
and really built a lot
of the scientific history
around a lot of advances
that we live off.
The point here is
we get a lot of--
I don't want to denigrate
Vannevar Bush's.
Stokes takes it on, and
attacks it, and criticizes it,
I think for some good reasons.
But we've gotten a
lot out of that model.
So federal research
support has just
been critical to the development
of just an incredible array
of advanced technologies,
and basic research
is behind a lot of that.
So it's a key enabler.
It's a key US
comparative advantage.
And interestingly, a big
advantage of basic research
is that it puts you out on
the frontier of science,
and you can get
scientific breakthroughs
from basic research.
If you're just doing incremental
applied work, particularly
at the development
stage, you're not
going to get the breakthroughs.
But if your door is
open to the basic stuff,
there's a lot of potential
breakthroughs lurking in there.
Now, getting them into
implementation is not simple,
but it is, overall, I think
an advantage in the US system
that we have strong
basic research.
What have we gotten?
NSF supported the
original funding
for the Google search engine.
GPS was founded on a
purely scientific Navy
effort around atomic clocks.
That's one of the foundational
technologies, as well
as DOD's Navstar system,
and work by DARPA.
Supercomputing really came
out of the DOE National Labs.
Speech recognition
came out of DARPA.
They funded all the work
behind Siri originally.
Siri is Stanford
Research Institute.
That was the development entity,
a basic research nonprofit.
DARPA, as you know,
did the ARPANET,
which led to the internet.
NIST did closed captioning.
All kinds of
critical technologies
came out of basic research, as
well as defense technologies
for the smartphone.
In energy, the whole
fracking revolution
came out of the Department
of Energy's lab research.
LEDs came from the Air Force.
MRIs came out of NSF and NIH.
The list goes on.
Human Genome Project, an
absolutely fundamental research
project, was led and
significantly influenced
by NIH.
Out of mathematics comes
things like reverse auctions,
which is a tool that we use
in a number of circumstances,
such as spectrum auctions.
One of the great
absolute breakthroughs
of early 20th
century agriculture,
a huge enabler in that
sector, is the development
of hybrid crops,
particularly hybrid corn,
which transforms the production
of corn in the United States.
Absolutely transformative.
Comes out of obscure
agricultural research stations
in places like Connecticut.
So there's a lot that we've
gotten out of basic research.
You can barely see this,
but it is a famous diagram
in computer science.
So it's called the
tire tracks diagram.
And you see these
kind of lanes and then
you see these tire tracks
weaving in and out of them.
And these are the foundational
work in computer science
and where it came from,
with university work leading
and almost initially
[INAUDIBLE]----
that's federally-funded
university research--
being often picked up
at a subsequent stage
by industry R&D, fed from
university to industry,
and then eventually emerging
in the green lines as billion
dollar product lines,
and then eventually,
the wider line, 10 billion
or more product lines.
So these are foundational
research efforts.
These are the technology
results that emerged.
There's a rich literature
behind every single one
of those lines--
small lines on this map.
So that famous
tire track diagram
is a critical diagram
developed by NSF
in explaining how the computing
revolution came about.
We're now at Donald
Stokes, and I'm just
going to summarize very briefly.
Stokes is a very
interesting figure here.
He was dean of the Woodrow
Wilson School at Princeton.
And he dies of leukemia very
tragically, and pretty early.
This is the last big thing.
Pasteur's quadrant is the
last big project he works on.
There's a lot of emotion in
this book that he puts together.
He feels these
issues very strongly,
as you could tell from his text.
And what he's confronting
is the relationship
between science and
government, which we've been
trying to dissect earlier on.
And he takes on the
Vannevar Bush basic research
model and talks about its
weaknesses and failures.
So federal support
of basic research--
his goal was to curtail
governmental control
of the performance
of that research.
That was one of the key
things Bush was up to.
And he aimed to
create, through NSF,
an entity with cross science
authority based on a way,
as I said earlier, on his
wartime scientific organization
attempts.
The rationale behind
creating NSF and supporting
basic research is
that basic research
is to be performed without
thought of practical ends.
That's one foundational feature.
That's what it is.
Let's not think
about practical ends,
let's just do the research.
And then secondly, basic
research will be, he argues--
Vannevar Bush
argues-- the pacemaker
of technological advance.
So again, he has got
a pipeline model.
Do basic research.
Dump that into the pipeline.
Mysterious things will occur.
Great technologies will emerge.
And his assumption is that
dumping that basic research
will pace what is going
on inside that pipeline.
It is a left right model.
The government is
dumping something
in on the left side
of the pipeline.
Great stuff is emerging on the
right side of the pipeline.
Now, remember Richard Nelson.
Nelson talked about the
way in which technology
influences science, as well as
science influencing technology.
Vannevar Bush does not
have a two-way street
of interaction between the two.
He has organized US science
on a one-way street,
a left to right--
it's not two lanes,
it's left to right.
So Stokes argues that that
is a critical organizational
failure, that that
radically limits
what you're going to be able
to get out of your system.
Skipping ahead here,
to conclude that point,
the Bush paradigm of the
linear relation between science
and technology, Stokes
argues, bears no resemblance
to their actual connection.
The reality is it's
a two-way street,
and we've only organized
a one-way street.
And therefore, this interaction
is not going to occur.
There are deep ties between
science and technology.
They're interactive,
they're not linear.
So the Vannevar Bush model
lasts and is respected really
until the 1980s.
And what's going
on in the 1980s?
We talked about this in class 3.
That's the great
competition with Japan.
And Japan builds a much
more connected system,
much deeper ties
between industry
and its research system--
in fact, its research system
is industry-led really.
The US has got this
disaggregated system.
Basic research is
off on the side.
The argument is the US is coming
up with the breakthroughs.
It's not able to implement them.
It is not turning
them into industries.
In fact, Japan is taking
the US breakthroughs
and turning them
into industries.
That's the story of a lot
of consumer electronics
in that period of time.
And Stokes is suggesting we've
got to get down to basics here.
We've got a fundamental
organizational problem.
It's not an accident
that this occurred,
it's the way we organize things.
That's why it happened.
And this is a very anxious
moment in US political history
when he's writing
here, because we're
starting to de-industrialize,
and with lots
of effects on a lot of
people in the United States.
So Stokes argues that Vannevar
Bush's model is static,
whereas, in fact, the
reality is dynamic,
and the static linear model
is not the right model.
So he short circuited
the thinking process.
He assumed, because
you do basic research,
implementation would follow.
But it doesn't necessarily
follow, Stokes argues.
It's one-dimensional.
Stokes's quadrant picture
is an important picture
to understand, because this is
the classic critique of many
of Vannevar Bush model, which
is the classic critique of US
science organization.
So all this stuff
we're reading here
is pretty noted material
in US science history.
Here is his Pasteur's
quadrant, which you all saw.
So there's four
quadrants, Stokes's mind,
and there's two axes--
are you searching for a
fundamental understanding, yes
or no, and are you
considering use,
considering the
utility of what you're
researching-- no and yes.
So he has this nice
quadrant, and then
to the upper-left
quadrant, where
you're searching for
fundamental understanding
but you're not
considering use, that's
like physics in the '20s.
That's like Niels Bohr.
They're figuring out
particle physics.
They don't see any
utility for this.
The idea comes along later
about atomic weapons,
but that's decades away.
So yes, we can understand
that is an interesting moment,
search for fundamental
understanding,
no consideration, really just
trying to understand stuff.
Then there's what he
calls Pasteur's quadrant,
and he argues this is the
one that Vannevar Bush's
model misses completely.
He's trying to organize as
though its particle physics,
but a lot of stuff isn't.
So Louis Pasteur, he's searching
for fundamental understanding.
He's doing microbiology at
a really fundamental scale,
but he's certainly
considering use.
He doesn't want kids to
die of bad milk in Paris.
He's considering use.
He's up to something here.
He's after a medical fix.
So that's a very good example
of basic research being
driven by consideration of use.
And Stokes doesn't want to
eliminate this quadrant--
he knows how productive it is--
but he sure wants to add
consideration of this quadrant.
Now, what are the
other two quadrants?
No search for fundamental
understanding,
and consideration of use.
So in here he puts
Thomas Edison.
That's like the light bulb.
Thomas Edison doesn't
really care about physics.
He just cares about
the light bulb.
But it turns out to be a
little more complicated,
and we'll talk about
this in class 7.
But Edison has got
scientists in that room,
in that idea factory,
as he calls it,
in Menlo Park, New Jersey, that
frame 100-foot-long building.
And they are onto some
scientific ideas here.
And there is something called
the Edison effect, which
actually helps explain
electron theory,
that Edison himself and some
of the other crew come up with.
So there is science evolving
out of the technology
that they're pursuing.
So it's consideration
of use, but they
are finding some fundamental
understandings here,
because it is a two-way street.
Now, the one that
makes no sense to me
is, is there anybody
really is not
searching for
fundamental understanding
and not considering use?
Who would do that?
So Stokes says, oh, Darwin.
Gets on a boat, has
a nice ocean voyage--
AUDIENCE: Sounds
like fun though.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --walks
around the Galapagos,
evolution dawns.
It's not the way it happened.
He gets on the Beagle
because he already
has developed a lot
of evolution theory.
In fact, his father
is a scientist
who's been working
on it before him,
so he has a very good idea of
why he's getting on that ship.
So I don't really know anybody
who quite fits there, because I
don't really think Darwin does.
Darwin really as
a pretty good idea
what scientific
theories he's going
to be pursuing, as he
sails around the world.
So I'm open to suggestions, if
anybody can think of someone.
But I think he feels this blank
in because it's a quadrant.
He has to put
something in there.
How does he think
it really works?
He comes up with this complex
diagram, which is very--
it's a little hard to follow.
He calls it Stokes's
dynamic model.
And you can see that
use-inspired research
is the big one.
Then there's pure
basic research,
and then there's
purely-applied research.
And then there's
this kind of system
between early understanding,
improved understanding,
and improved technology,
and existing technology.
And everything swirling
around, but this
is right at the center.
That's kind of his idea
of how it really works.
And his critique
of Vannevar Bush
is you're putting
all your bets here,
and you have to think
about this, as well.
So that's Stokes's critique.
And the fact that the US
was doing great science
and not making it
is what drives him
to this set of realizations
about these fundamentals of how
we've organized our science and
technology system in the US.
So Sanam, it's all yours.
AUDIENCE: OK, well, I guess I'll
just start with some thoughts
that I had on basic research
in general from both these two
readings.
So it seems, we've been reading,
a major downfall or obstacle
to basic research is
that the payoffs are
risky and uncertain,
especially in the short run.
And that's kind of what
shareholders are generally
most concerned about
is short on profits.
And so that kind of hinders
the long-term investments
in basic research,
which potentially
have really large positive
externalities, as we've
been seeing.
And there's also--
I think Stokes mentioned this--
there's also a low incentive
because the original investor
often doesn't reap
the most benefits
from whatever eventually
comes of the basic research.
And the profits are
spread throughout society,
and not always
concentrated [INAUDIBLE]..
So investing in and
instigating basic research is--
there's a lower
incentive for that.
And I think that's an
argument to classify it
as a public good,
which is really
in favor of saying the
government should be--
or federal support
should be there
for providing this public
good quote, unquote
"of basic research."
And I think that's a very good
argument for the necessity
of federal support.
But the other thing
I was thinking of
is that are there ways of
expanding this from just--
the responsibility,
shifting it just
from that of the federal
government to other actors?
So some thoughts that I had
when I was doing these readings
were--
and I'll put this
question to you
guys-- is there a way to
change the payoff structure
so that the responsibility
to provide funding
for basic research can be
on industries, as well?
Or is there a way to have
an integrated system that
encourages multiple and
synergistic benefits
that both firms, private
actors, and maybe
even some public actors all
want to kind of buy into?
And I think that
gets us closer to--
Singer mentions the rich
ecosystem following post--
after the war, where
it wasn't a situation
of a lone innovator working
by themselves or anything.
So that's one of the main
things I've been trying
to process with these readings.
So I guess the more
general question to you
all would be with--
how to change the system so
that private and public funding
relationships can work
together, and also
can be cognizant of the
different agendas and goals
of the different actors within
the institutionalized science
framework that we've
been looking at.
Any thoughts?
AUDIENCE: I wonder who
it connects to the energy
industry [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I feel like
I'm repeating myself,
but when I was first here, we
talked about patient capital
and this breakthrough energy.
And [INAUDIBLE] one of the
proposals there was definitely
a public partner--
a public private partnership
with different countries,
including the US.
And unfortunately,
it's not happening
in the US of committing
to double their R&D
budgets around energy.
And then, again, this
is just Bill Gates
and his billionaires club.
But it could be other
sources of private capital,
and we're starting to see
some other sources pledging
to pick up what that--
what they were calling
mission innovation that
bringing basic research
ideas further along,
pick those up, and
incubate them longer.
The MIT Energy
Initiative doesn't
solve all the world's problems,
but there's definitely
early stage research
that we fund--
that part of every company's
membership they put
$100,000 a year into a pool, and
we fund what we call commonly
around MIT different people
are doing seed grants.
So I could go on about
that, but we have--
AUDIENCE: Do you mean like in
Media Lab, because the Media
Lab models--
I forget how much they get paid
for each company [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: We have
something like that,
but nobody gets IP
at the Media Lab.
Nobody gets IP for
what I just described,
for the early stage stuff.
Because we also bring
in like $30 million
a year of money for
sponsored research.
But Bill, I don't know if
you want to say anything
that ARPA-E. That's also a part
of the Department of Energy
that's modeled after DARPA, that
definitely funds early stage.
And a bunch of MIT faculty
have gotten those grants.
I don't know how much it's
under threat at the moment.
I guess a piece of ARPA-E is.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: ARPA-E
is proposed to be eliminated.
AUDIENCE: The total piece.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's not even
a lot of money, right?
It's like $103 million?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
It's $300 million.
AUDIENCE: 300, OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Only
at the federal government
would that not be
a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: Does any of that
address what you were--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But Sanam, you're
driving it really
interesting points.
What are some other
organizational models
that might help us get around
some of these dilemmas?
And it's a really
intriguing set of questions.
AUDIENCE: Going back
to some of the--
not even organizational
stuff, but some of the stuff
that we talked about
earlier like new accounting
methods, or increased
tax benefits
for doing basic science
research and things like that.
If you don't mind, I had a
question about this reading.
So he kind of pokes holes in
Bush's linear relationship
between basic R&D and
development-- or basic research
and development.
So he creates this quadrant,
and I didn't really
gather from it so much what he
was recommending from a policy
perspective how
you de-distribute
funding across those three
or four sections differently.
I didn't see that much in
the reading [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
In a way, Matthew,
you're asking,
is Stokes attacking what's
really kind of a paper tiger?
Does this system that
Stokes is describing
of the federal
government really only
funding pure basic research
along the Vannevar Bush lines--
does that really exist?
And I think there actually
is a serious question.
So in the next
class, class 6, we're
going to dive pretty
deeply into that
question-- how does the
system actually work?
I've just described the
Vannevar Bush model,
which dominates US
civilian science
and the major scientific
organizations that
are part of it.
So NIH, NSF, DOE,
Office of Science
are all organized on a
basic research model.
But then there's a parallel
universe in the US R&D system.
The Defense Innovation system is
not organized like that at all.
It's back to World War II.
It's a much more
connected system.
So we're going to
explore that in class 6
in a fair amount of depth.
But the agencies
themselves have changed.
They've evolved over time.
So for example, at
NSF itself, which
is the classic basic
research organization--
NSF's probably greatest
director, Eric Bloch,
who died tragically recently--
great, great figure in science.
He's the only NSF director
to come out of industry,
so he was part of that amazing
IBM team that did a lot of--
that won the president's
Medal of Technology
for some of their really
early computing advances.
So he comes out of the
computer science arena.
And so he walks into NSF.
He sees this basic
research agency.
He sees that they all
seem to want computers,
but they have no idea of
what computer science is.
So he creates a whole new branch
of science, computer science,
and builds a strong support
system for computer science
organizations and departments.
DARPA had previously
been funding those.
Suddenly, NSF is landing
in that space, as well.
In addition, he embraces
the engineering division.
He himself is an
engineer from RPI.
He embraces the
engineering division
and brings in a whole set
of much more connected
collaborative engineering
research centers
and related programs
that are going
to be much more connected into
the system than most of NSF is.
So even these
agencies themselves
tend to push further down
the innovation pipeline
than just the early
stage research, even
an organization like NSF.
So there's an evolving
story here on how US science
organizations is structured.
And when you read an
article in the next class
about new model
innovation agencies,
we're going to confront
some of those issues.
So in the next
class, we're going
to talk about the parallel
Defense Innovation
organization, which
is very connected,
as well as the evolution of
these agencies themselves.
So it's not as if
things have stood still.
Stokes's critique has been
understood and accepted,
in some ways, in some parts
of these other agencies,
although they still remain
basic research-based.
So it's an evolving
story here, Matthew.
Sanam, how about one more
question-- or a couple more?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so getting
at the idea of short-term
versus longer-term,
if we're looking
at that top-right
quadrant where it's
use-considered
basic research, do
you think that that's
still a little-- there's
a lot of emphasis on innovation
being centered there.
Do you think that's
still focused on
short to medium-term visions,
and excluding the longer-term,
or do you think there's
also the space for more
long-term approach?
AUDIENCE: So I think just one
example [INAUDIBLE] like DARPA.
Because I worked on a
project with exoskeletons.
It was funded by
DARPA, and they--
it was consideration-based.
They were looking for the
next generation of soldiers.
And the projects that
they were funding
were super early stage,
down to [INAUDIBLE] basics
of biomechanics, and energy
usage, and metabolics,
biowalking, [INAUDIBLE].
So I do think there are some
examples of a longer-term while
still considering use.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
it's harder and harder
to think of examples of
pure basic research now.
Obviously, there are still some.
Like astrophysics
research and understanding
the universe might still
fall into that category.
But I think a lot of
what people are doing,
people have some
sort of idea of what
an end goal might be in it.
Like biotech
applications can go back
to very basic bio research.
And now people
doing that research
are thinking about
how it might be
able to be used in the future.
So I think that is
definitely still long-term.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Steph, I like your point.
And an MIT scientist
once explained to me
how it actually works.
He said, look, on
day one, I'm doing
fundamental exploratory science.
And I may do that for a
considerable period of time.
Then I see something.
Some kind of
opportunity pattern.
Suddenly, I'm doing applied
science, because something--
I've seen something.
I've seen what the
possibilities are.
And then I'll play with that,
and then it doesn't work,
so then I'm back doing
fundamental exploratory basic
science again for a while.
It's a dynamic process here.
I think Stokes is right.
It's not a static
linear process.
And often, the
scientists themselves
will move between basic
and later-stage work
on a single research project,
based upon what they're
discovering and finding.
The National
Institutes of Health
is pretty much a basic
research organization,
but when you go to the
National Institutes of Health,
you don't apply
to them for money.
You apply to the National
Cancer Institute.
So you're not applying to the
National Institute Let's Go
Have Fun in the Laboratory.
You're applying to the
National Cancer Institute.
So there is some
use-inspired elements,
even in a pretty basic
research organization like NIH.
How about a closing
point, Sanam?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
follow-up really quick?
You mentioned that this has now
become sort of the seminal work
in science technology policy.
I was curious--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That Stokes is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes, it is.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you could
talk about the
immediate reception
when he published it-- or when
it was published posthumously.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: War.
A fundamental
ethos of scientists
is we're doing basic fundamental
research, exploratory research.
Data has enormous value.
And here's Stokes telling us
that we're missing something.
Shove it was a lot
of the reaction.
Nobody quite said that, because
Stokes was dying of leukemia.
But that was pretty
much the tenor.
And that's still a
ongoing debate here.
MIT, in some ways, is a
very unique institution,
because at the beginning, at the
foundational moment in 1860s,
it attempted to integrate
engineering and science.
Remember we talked about
at the very beginning--
engineering is
organized around--
in the 19th century,
it was making stuff.
It was doing things.
That's what engineering
was all about.
Science was natural philosophy.
It was observational.
It was understanding how
the natural world operates.
MIT attempted to bring these
two fields together and put them
on a continuum.
So there may be a pure
natural scientist at MIT--
and there are-- and there
may be some pure engineers,
but mostly, they're all
on a continuum together.
And the organizational mechanism
that MIT uses to do that
is not the departments.
So most universities
have the departments
at their core,
which are organized
around single scientific fields.
Departments are
important at MIT,
because they determine
credentialing,
and do you have a job,
and can you teach,
and what are you going to teach.
They're important.
But the really powerful
elements are the labs at MIT,
and they integrate
all kinds of fields,
and they are use-driven.
They are very much
results-driven.
So they're bringing together
science and engineering
on a continuum, but with a
set of organized purposes.
So it's a pretty unique
organizational model.
It's not the pervasive
model in US universities.
So this debate doesn't really
break out that much at MIT,
because MIT already
did the integration.
But at many other places,
it's an ongoing debate.
So Sanam, a closing thought?
I keep-- what do you think?
AUDIENCE: Something
that's really
in my mind,
especially right now,
is just the direction that this
debate is going to take on,
especially considering you've
got to go through the budget
and everything.
So I think that means a
lot for a lot of areas
that are outside the reach
of market in general.
And especially with
science funding,
it seems like defense
is the clear winner
with this new budget.
So I think that
that kind of might
signal a
re-prioritization that is
going to have some
interesting implications
for this whole debate.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's
a really important point.
This is a pretty seminal moment
in US scientific history.
So the organizational
set of assumptions
that the Vannevar
Bush put into place
at the close of World War II of
federal support for research,
it's really being--
in question now.
And this is the largest
cutback of a federal science
support in history
that's now been proposed.
Is the model ending?
Is this amazing system of
federally-supported research
universities-- is
that being phased out?
So it's a very critical time
to consider these questions.
This is the model that
we've had up to now.
This is the first
time I've really
seen a pretty fundamental
hit on that model.
Now, whether Congress
takes it or not, we'll see.
It's going to be playing
out in the next few months.